mm-hmm and that's supposed to tell you
something this Crystal represents
courage
this represents Beauty
okay spot on sofa
and what does the bag of rocks say about
you
let's find out
only by working together
[Music]
our moon is crying out for help I sense
her pain she needs us to protect her let
me guess that someone is US someone
needs to do something last time we
listened to you we almost ended up in
jail I thought we were a Sisterhood
you're going too far Margo it's getting
scary
I should go me too
you're not going with them
nah I've got nowhere else to be she's a
risk taker now I like it come on I want
to show you something
you're going too bad
we're almost there are you big baby
[Music]
that's beautiful
so are you this suits you I feel like
the whole world is opened up now that
I'm myself I'm glad
funny isn't it and the moon may be dying
but it's this place that's broken
do you really think Cleo will collapse
not if I can help it
give me your hand
[Music]
creativity a compassion leadership
[Music]
really
I only tell you what the Palm tells me
you're much stronger than you realize
you've already been through so much
transitioning
sort of hard
but look at you now
you'll go on to do great things
this it has been seen
why did you bring me here
I have a plan to save Cleo
oh what it's dangerous
whatever it is I'm in
Hammond isn't here to help
they're building that thing just strip
Cleo
to consume her
and we're gonna stop them
wow
you didn't say anything about bomb why
did you think we were doing here
stop
people could get hurt
the woman who saved Cleo
do the Rocks tell you what happened to
her
they only tell you what you already know
that I had to come here to protect my
true home
after a bit of luck
okay now do Sheila she's an all Moody
naked
[Music]
foreign
[Music]